ce rocher
en ce graphisme de de
Pierre bien de pas les mettre au
milieu bouge un petit peu tu veux qu'on
passe audessus qu'on le qu'on l'enroule
oui un tout
doucement
[Musique]
il foncé une
merde
un petit plan général de la
vallée pr le T délimité avec des pierres
tous les champs sont délimités avec des
pierres
un pe
ver laall tu vois tous les gens qui
travaillent partant le debout d'ici je
sais
pas bne ID j
dans très joli chit en pierre c'est
drôle j
[Musique]
ça
pourire
incroyable
doucement pas trop
vite magnifique
ça
on fait un plan
ça de suite après commence
voir
les gens qui travaillent devant
génial dou comme ça tu narrê pas comme
ça
bien d'ord génial génial c'est
super
j'adore comprend ce qui se passe on VO
le truc c'est
super
ils font les petits barrages partout et
toute l'eau est rationné des mecs qui
font des puitsis
tout un
systèmeéchange d'eau m de
l'eauau I Je suiscument
mon bien c'est bien en bas c'est la fin
derni Contin encore un petit peu sera
bien qu'on finiss voil la fin de la
vallé je pense qu' a
plus
voilà ça c'est la
fin fin sur un arbre
ouais le plus voilà ça l'utre sens un
petit coup le temps ou pas le temps
façon on va se poser on va faire la
petite fille on va voir pu on puis on
viendra je pense pas qu'on aura assez
pour faire la peti fille maintenant P
dans les Noirs wou qu'est-ce qu' nous
fait lui
OK
qui on va directement voir ouais